[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors votre pièce comédie tragédie
tragédie comédie le petit robot merkel
savinien cyrano
un poète avec un grand
c'est bien ce sera très bien il faut
juste que de figure les répétitions
commencent demain matois et la cathay
pacific
volcker a monté par pur bijou ça manque
un peu depuis
marchera jamais
votre verve amusé à cet acte n'était pas
poussé le directeur du monde
que voulez-vous que j'y fasse qui parle
ou et bien mes amis ça sans succès je
vous préviens cher myrmidon car la fin
de l'envoi je louche je touche
nous allons modestement créer ensemble
un chef-d'oeuvre
comme à chaque fois voici l'auteur
edmond rostand génie comme à chaque fois
dites moi que tout va bien se passer
tout va bien se passer
le ken price l'us postal je ne sais pas
et roxane qui fêtait je ne sais pas ils
respirent les gorillaz
je sens quelque chose dans cette pièce
comme si je dis à vous tous que je n'ai
pas le courage et l'héroïsme l'amour à
moi
sur le dic hull
je n'ai jamais vu
[Applaudissements]